well it's just the morning after  halloween so likely you still have a lot  of your decorations up maybe your  jack-o'-lantern still sitting on the  front porch now when you're ready to get  rid of those don't toss them in the  trash you know they can be recycled the  real pumpkins can feed pigs and chickens  through las vegas livestock now there  are several locations around town can  see the j.r the j.w marriott  gilchrist orchard up in the north valley  just look for the designated containers  those are available 24 hours a day  all through this week through friday so  go feed some livestock put those  pumpkins to use john the livestream